And there you want to see that all high enough as needed.
No, man, you're free.
So, y 'all coin welcome to 20 minute leaders.
Thank you so much for being with me today.
How are you?
I'm very well.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you for doing great to have an audience.
Absolutely.
For you.
I hope that people will understand many things that still seem like science fiction.
Let's talk about science fiction.
I got your co founder and CEO of Cogni fiber.
in the space of photonic computing.
What is that?
So photonic computing in the basic, it's computing with photon instead of electrons.
So our whole technology world today is based on electronics mostly.
But until now we didn't have any issue with it.
I mean, it functioned very well.
We did amazing things with that.
until we reached AI.
AI.
And artificial intelligence is really challenging for any type of hardware.
because the demand for trillions of operation every second is very heavy on the hardware.
And you can see then the cost of hardware and the cost of operation and the electrical
bills and the cooling it needs.
needs.
It's simply because when you want to transfer trillions of electrons every second through
wires,
they heat up and they cannot move as fast as photons.
So 11 years ago, I asked myself, okay, we have very nice optical communication, high
speed, very low power.
especially the fibers, because they are really, really efficient in transferring photons.
So what if we can replace the electronics with fiber -based photonic computing?
That means to take a fiber, which is a piece of glass, elongated glass, and somehow to
turn it from something that carries
carries photons from point A to point B to something that processes the data when the
photons pass through it.
And that's the basic idea.
the basic idea.
if I understand correctly, a big part of it is adapting the photonic technology from just
being a data transfer layer to also having a compute capability, right?
Yeah.
Yes.
I mean, we can look at the basic example if we want to implement, let's say, a gate.
electronic gate, a simple AND gate, OR gate.
or gates or you want to implement a neuron like an artificial neural network so if we can
do it in photonics it would be very fast you could reach let's say 100 gig today 200 gig
400 gig
And on the other hand, it wouldn't take a lot of power.
It wouldn't heat up as much.
up as much.
So that seems like a win -win situation.
win -win situation.
so tell me a little bit about the where we're at in terms of productization and just for
that so that we have a good basis for the market landscaping.
So where are we at today with this technology, with companies building on top of the
promise of photonic computing?
And what timelines are we talking about?
So we have today in the world about two or three main technologies of photonic computing.
of photonic computing.
The first family is based on silicon chips.
chips.
And they are all silicon prototypes for photonic integrated circuits.
And that's adding additional layers on top of silicon chips so they can become waveguides,
guide light.
to glide the light.
And most of the companies today use these technologies.
The main issue is the packaging of the processors and scalability.
scalability.
So if we want to implement, for example, HHGPT or other generative AI models,
AI models, we need hundreds of billions of processors or let's say parameters.
the downside with photons is their wavelength.
Their wavelength is much longer than electrons.
That means that every component is much larger.
So let's say 10 by 10 microns, for example, as compared to a transistor of several
hundreds of nanometers.
of nanometers.
So that's about one to one hundredth ratio, could be one to thousandth ratio.
So things are bigger.
things are here, but they're much faster and lower on energy.
On the other hand, when we look at fibers.
fibers.
The issue of packaging is similar.
is similar.
But the scalability is much easier.
much better.
Because we can just connect fibers to fibers.
In regular fashion, you can find the means of them in data centers.
so we can actually physically build very large network of processors.
of processors.
So is this the world that we're heading into that data centers and the data computation
layer within our hardware eventually will be fiber and photons instead of what we have
today?
So I think eventually, if we look 50 years ahead, we'll have three types of computing
machines.
we'll have the quantum machines
quantum machines.
for specific problems, which are, let's say, very hard, very complex.
very complex.
We'll have the photonic machines, which can do, let's say, trillions of full operations
every second.
That means accelerate about a million times from today.
from today.
let's say instead of millions of inferences per second, we'll go to billions and trillions
of inference per second.
And of course we'll still have the electronics for control, for training, for a lot of
things, which are more convenient to, make sure eventually we might go to fully photonics.
photonics.
but it will take a lot of time.
So that's the vision.
that's the vision.
So yeah, tell me about...
give an example...
Yeah, go ahead.
one photonic machine, let's say 10 years ago, 10 years ahead, 10 years ahead, will replace
half of the data center today.
the data center today okay that's the ratio of computing capabilities
Wow.
Okay.
So, Eyal, tell me a little bit about...
Tell me about Cogni Fiber.
now you're an entrepreneur in the space.
Tell me about the company founded, the journey so far, and really what is it that you're
bringing to be part of the larger vision of photonics in the world?
Yeah.
So, Cogni Fiber is about a very unique connection.
between the world of optics and photonics, represented by our CTO, Professor Zev Zalevsky,
which is a world -renowned photonic researcher.
photonic researcher.
And myself, coming from both hardware, but also the brain research, as my PhD was in
neuroscience.
And I'm lecturing about the brain for 20 years now.
for 20 years now.
So this combination of hardware, brain, neuroscience, and optics is
is something which is unique to cognitive fiber.
And we use this advantage.
We look at the brain.
We look for how the brain does it efficiently.
How does it compute?
I what's the difference between regular computers and servers and the brain?
and the brain?
Of course we are not alone.
The field of neuromorphics is a very wide field.
Dealing with that.
But I think that stepping into the knowledge that I gathered about the brain.
about the brain for the last 20 years with the knowledge that I bring, that is the major
advantage and also the source of differentiating the complex.
So for example, our vision for inference systems, the systems where the data streams in
from regular fibers in the data centers and streams through the system and does the
inference without any reading or writing to memory.
That is a unique, let's say, strategy.
strategy.
And I'm...
which give us a very strong advantage in latency and throughput.
and throughput.
And how does the product then come to market?
What is the product that you're building for the layman?
We start with small networks and it will grow gradually.
So we look at the text here, we'll have machine learning systems
which are very, very fast, especially low latency.
They could go for the market, for example, high frequency trading, where every microsecond
counts.
Or they go to data center switching to make the training of AI generative models much more
efficient.
Is the play here to work with the larger hardware companies to bring this to market as
part of their hardware or what is the play to market here?
Yes, first we want to show the world that this actually works and works well.
So the first POCs will probably without a large partners and then we can get the traction.
get the traction.
Yes, we are in contact with Intel, with Samsung, with Nvidia, and some of them are really
waiting to see how our first products work.
They understand the value.
value.
And so when you show the product and you try to express the value, what are the key
metrics that
that you care about?
Is it mainly the latency and the efficiency of the computation?
Yeah.
If we look at the first product, the simple ones, it's mostly about real time, pattern
recognition.
And we talk about, let's say two up to 10 nanoseconds delay.
That's something which is, does not exist today.
not exist today.
If we talk about future systems, which are larger,
We're talking about, let's say the total cost of ownership of a query for let's say
generative AI, but also latency because the customers do want very short latency.
short latency.
So people talk about throughput and how to divide the bandwidth between customers, et
cetera.
speed is of the essence.
of the essence.
And but if you look also, there are some fields that cannot exist today.
So we, and we are enablers.
For example, smart city.
So today, if a smart city wants to connect 100 ,000 cameras, they need a data center.
Okay.
And they cannot afford a data center.
a data center.
most cities.
And if we can provide them a system, let's say 30, 40 million dollars, does most of the
work.
Let's say only a small room with several other pods.
several other pods That would be enough So then you can have a smart city I mean and the
electrical bill will be you know about
kilowatts, 50 kilowatts, and not 20 megawatts.
20 megabits.
That's a basic revolution.
revolution.
Amazing.
Wow.
So Eyal, what's coming up in the next couple months for Cognifiber?
We are very excited because we are going to present our first prototype, and it's actually
MVP.
And with this presentation somewhere along the next Q1 2025, we are going to present this
technology.
this technology.
The aim is at least one giga inference per second.
per second.
and with power consumption of up to 100 watts.
up to 100 fat.
And that's like, you know, saying we are here.
There's a new technology in the, know, rising up and you better not miss it.
not miss it.
Absolutely.
Eyal, thank you so much for coming and for sharing your journey.
Sounds like we're in it for the long haul.
especially it sounds like this is a very foundational and very fundamental technology that
will change how we experience a lot of different existing use cases, new use cases.
And of course, we're all getting less and less patient every day.
So considering the impact of latency.
and the speed, think that's really the key here.
So Eyal, thank you again and best of luck with Cognifiber.
Thank you.
Thank you too, Michael.
Thank you for the time.
Thank you so much.